I'm Bill Merck. I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 159 in Pasco, Washington.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like us.
And now to you, Scout Master.
I was trying to sharpen my pocket knife the other day, but
well, to put it bluntly, there was really no point to it.
Oh my, yes, send me a new joke please.
Hey, this is podcast number 234..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Bob Moneymaker got in touch with us and Bob is a committee chair
with Troop and crew 690 in the Golden Empire Council in Sacramento, California,
And he wrote in about the post that we had last week- Little League and Scouting-
And he said: oh my gosh, how true is this?
Never thought of it this way before. Thanks for the excellent comparison.
I'll be sure to use this in training and committee meetings and anywhere else it may apply.
We also heard about the same post from Patrick Thompson.
from Patrick Thompson who said also: Little League or any other sport
is not a participatory thing for adults.
They don't get to bat or pitch the ball or run to bases.
There are the observers.
Scouting is a little bit different, even though we're not in the action,
we're a little bit more participatory.
Scouting offers a great vantage point to watch your child grow
while you rediscover your childhood as an adult.
Also heard from Tom Dewey, who is an advisor
with Venturing Crew 6 in Gastonia, North Carolina,
And he wrote to say congratulations on your retirement.
30 years is one heck of a run.
Think of all of the young lives you've influenced.
I've been a Scouter for almost 20 years
and it never worked out that I'd be a Scout Master,
But I'm now a Venturing Advisor and starting a new crew.
It's a great time to be a Venturer.
Yes, indeed, it is, Tom.
That's what I'm in the middle of too.
So, yep, it's pretty interesting, isn't it?
Speaking of Venturing and Scouting and all that kind of wonderful things,
I want to take you to Switzerland next summer-
That's right, in the summer of 2015,-
to the Bernese Oberlin, and to enjoy the fellowship
of the continuous mini-world jamboree
that awaits you and your Scouts
at Condorsteg International Scout Center.
Now, I've successfully provided that opportunity
for my Scouts a couple of times,
and it's an incredible experience.
You can see the videos of our 2014 trip at ScoutMasterCGcom.
I'd like to host your group in 2015..
And to do just that I've tentatively secured accommodations.
I've started working out all of the planning
and the administrative things that need to happen,
so you don't have to worry about it.
I have two weeks set aside in late June
and early July of next summer.
Week one starts on June 20th.
Week two starts on June 27th.
Both of those are Saturdays.
Now, to make this idea viable,
I need a minimum number of participants
to make a commitment to attend by October 1st,
And that's coming up very, very soon.
Your group can be of any size.
I can handle up to 50 participants each week.
The next step is for you to get in touch with me.
Email me at clark C-L-A-R-K-E at ScoutMasterCGcom.
There are two or three groups that have contacted me thus far
who are interested, and we're getting things put together,
So get in touch. Condorsteg 2015..
You know there were a couple of comments
about a pulse we had on the podcast
this past week- Little League and Scouting-
And I want to thank Dave Klein for his contribution.
Dave wrote, Dave and I collaborated on getting that post out.
The one thing that I think is really an interesting point there
is that parents understand sports better than they understand scouting,
because they get to sit in the bleachers
and watch sports like baseball happen,
And they don't really get to see what happens in scouting.
in quite the same way,
They're not necessarily going to understand exactly how it all works,
And so our challenge is to communicate that to them.
Read the post.
It's Little League and Scouting, and you'll see it at ScoutMasterCGcom.
Let's see.
Over the past week, too, I published an infographic
about keeping your camping gear dry
by doing something horrible and heretical:
Putting your ground cloth inside your tent.
This is a piece of advice that I got from a book
by one of my favorite authors, Cliff Jacobson.
He wrote a book called Camping's Top Secrets,
And it just came to me last week.
You know what
More people would understand how this works
if there was an infographic about it.
So I made up an infographic.
I sent it to Cliff for a quick check
before I published it last week,
And he said: you did a terrific job explaining the concept
and easy to understand visual form-
Best explanation I've ever seen.
My hat's off too.
I love it.
Well, thank you, Cliff.
Sometimes all it takes is getting a picture
of exactly what's going on to people
And they understand it a little bit better.
So do go and check out the infographic
And it's also part of the Scoutmaster CG PDF package.
I've put together a whole package in a zipped file,
a number of infographics and other helpful
that you'll find available at scoutmastercgcom.
Let's see
One more thing here before we get going.
If you're a regular reader and listener,
if the information that we're offering has helped you,
you can return the favor
by making a one-time contribution
as a scoutmastercgcom backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the blog posts
and the podcast and the videos
and all the other resources
that are accessible to scouts all over the world.
It's a pretty easy thing to do.
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose any level of support,
And some of them entitle you to premiums
like autographed copies of my books.
I want to take a moment to personally thank Ron Blaisdell,
who signed on as a backer since our last podcast.
Thank you so much for your contribution, Ron.
Really really appreciate the help
in making all of this possible.
In this week's podcast I've got one thing for you,
and it's going to be in scoutmastership,
in seven minutes or less,
and it's never seven minutes
and it's never less than seven minutes
and it's often more,
and I have a feeling this week
is probably going to end up being more.
And that is just some thoughts
about resolving difficulties
and I hope you'll find that useful.
So, without any further ado,
let's get started, shall we
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
I get a fair number of emails
with questions about policy and procedure
and things like that,
but I would say they are equaled,
if not surpassed, by the numbers of emails
that I get with people asking my advice
about how to resolve some kind of problem
that they're running into
in their troop or their pack or their crew.
One that recently came over the wire said
we're experiencing some difficulty in our troop
and it's causing animosity between the scoutmaster
and the assistant scoutmasters
and the committee members,
and they went on to ask my advice
about how to solve it.
I get emails from parents
whose scouts are having difficulties
getting along with the adults
who are volunteering for their troop.
I get emails about adults arguing with each other.
If you've spent any amount of time in scouting,
you know that we have difficulties and problems
and obstacles to overcome once in a while.
One of the things
that I think really helps with this
is a little bit of perspective.
You know this is all nothing new.
This has been going on for as long
as scouting has been around,
and before there was scouting
there were other things.
and you know we're dealing with human beings,
and human beings can be a little unpredictable
and a little temperamental,
and we have to work with each other.
Baden Powell wrote this about a century ago
when he was confronted with one of these issues.
He said: it is almost beyond belief
that grown-up or nearly grown-up adults
can take little matters so seriously
and so narrowly as some of them do.
If they only had a sense of humor
or had a slightly wider range of view
so that they could see the other side of the question
or its greater aim,
they too would smile at the littleness of it all.
I was bealed to the other day in a case
which was evidently considered
of vast importance by the contending parties,
but which would have seemed ridiculously simple
to an outsider who saw both sides
and the higher motive
which was supposed to be their joint aim.
My reply to them
was one which might apply to many similar cases
where the contestants
cannot at once see the right line to take,
and it was this:
It is curious to me
that men who profess to be good Christians
often forget,
in a difficulty of this kind,
to ask themselves the simple question:
what would Christ have done
under the circumstances?
and be guided accordingly.
Try it the next time you are in difficulty or doubt
as to how to proceed.
That very good advice still rings true today.
It's a century later. it still rings true today,
and while Baden Powell called upon people
to emulate the founder of the faith
that he followed,
I do want to make sure that everybody understands
that whether you follow Christianity as a faith
is not really what's important here,
but that we use the example
and the tenets of conflict resolution
about getting along
and assuming goodwill.
Now there are conflicts and difficulties between adults
and there's conflicts and difficulties
between adults and scouts.
For some reason,
there are a lot of adult volunteers
who feel they have to be hard on scouts
and they get a little overheated
or they want to prove a point
or win some actually really pointless power struggle
with a scout between the ages of 11 to 18..
When you look at it,
come on,
Really, we can work this out right
if goodwill will work it out,
If everybody just kind of cools their jets a little bit
and gains some perspective, as Baden Powell said,
having a sense of humor
or a slightly wider range of view,
a different perspective,
so that you can see the other side of the question
and it's greater aim.
You will probably do what I do a lot of times
when I get these emails
and that is kind of a smile
at the littleness of it all,
because in the end,
a lot of this does not amount to a hill of beans.
Let's take a step back
and give the whole thing some thought
and find more compassion and understanding.
All too often, when these conflicts come up,
it's the failure of people involved
to possess the compassion and understanding
required of scouts
to transform difficulties and conflicts
into positive experiences.
Sometimes all we need to solve these monster,
what looks like monstrous problems
but are really not,
is a slight shift in attitude.
What would things look like
if our first assumption
when confronted with any one of these conflicts
or difficulties
was the assumption of goodwill?
The patrol leader who forgot to do something
may have honestly forgotten to do it,
not just willfully ignored their responsibility.
I forget all kinds of things
I don't know about you,
so we assume goodwill,
The scout who earned
three merit badges last month.
you know what?
they may have worked hard to achieve something
rather than trying just to get around
your standards.
I would assume goodwill.
an honest misunderstanding between
adults, or an honest misunderstanding
between scouts,
or an honest misunderstanding
between scouts and adults.
it's not a punishable crime.
I would assume goodwill
if you have to explain something
to someone for the thousandth time
and who hasn't had to do that.
I know
you know what.
it might just be
that we're not communicating well,
rather than
they're failing to listen.
I would assume goodwill
if it looks like someone's pulling in the other direction.
look for good intentions
in what they're doing
before you start pulling back.
I would assume goodwill
that the scout sitting across from you
at the scout master's conference.
they're doing their best,
so assume goodwill on their part.
the scout sitting across from you
at the border review is doing their best.
assume goodwill on their part.
an eagle candidate
is conducting his project
and finding his way through the process
and the best way that he knows how.
assume goodwill.
our assumption of goodwill
is really the key
because it starts us from the perspective
of that. other people aren't necessarily wrong.
we just may misunderstand what they're up to.
let me read you another quote
from Bate and Powell.
he says:
brothers we are to our boys,
brothers to each other,
we must be
if we're going to do any good.
aloofness or jealousy could not exist
where there is a true ideal of brotherhood.
what we need,
and what, thank God, we've got in most places in our movement,
is not merely the spirit of good nature,
tolerance,
but of watchful sympathy and readiness
to help one another.
we don't only need this,
but we've got to have it
if we're going to teach our boys
by the only sound way,
that is, through our example,
that the greatest principles
are goodwill and cooperation.
so if you're listening to this podcast,
it's more than likely that you are an adult volunteer
in scouting,
that you have some responsibilities
and things to take care of
and that on occasion you feel unappreciated.
I think that feeling has more to do a lot of times
with conflicts and difficulties that arise
than anything else.
so let me tell you about my buddy, Burke.
I don't think Burke really cared too much
about what other people had to say
about the ceremonial campfires he built
for our scout camp,
and they are some really impressive campfires
we're talking about,
you know, a graduated pyramid of campfire
that stands about six feet tall-
just beautiful things.
what he cared about most
was not what everybody else said about them
but what he had to think of them himself.
now I can recall some occasions
where, at least in my eye,
engaging the reaction of the people who were watching the campfire.
the campfire performed perfectly.
they lit easily,
they flooded the ceremonial campfire circle with light.
they died down at the appropriate time in the program,
like they were on a timer almost.
but to Burke's eye
there may have been some slight imperfection,
something it improved upon.
is he always immune to what people had to say about them?
well, I don't think so.
I don't think any of us are immune to what we hear people say about what we do.
but his own standard was the important benchmark,
not his expectation about how others would react to his work
because, seriously, he could have put a lot less effort
into building those campfires
than he did
and people probably wouldn't have noticed.
but it was important to him to get it right.
our expectations for acceptance of
an engagement in our work
as volunteers can have unintended results.
I don't know about you,
but I know I get disappointed and discouraged
when people's reactions don't meet my expectations.
we can get subtly or not so subtly aggressive or resentful,
and this colors the work that we do with our scouts or our fellow leaders.
now if I'm disappointed in the reaction that my work as a scouter receives,
I'm really tempted just to kind of tell everybody off
and take my ball and bat and go home.
but you know that's not the thing to do right
now. if we didn't attach a personal value
to the acceptance of our work
but only to the work itself,
how would that change our approach?
if we didn't allow our personal expectations to get in way of the program,
what would happen?
now? I'm not suggesting that you lower the expectations you have for yourself.
I'm saying: don't have expectations for the way people are going to react.
now that sounds a little impossible
and maybe even a little heretical,
but give it some thought.
if we keep working hard
and we don't tie that work to an expectation
about how people are going to react to it,
that means that we'll be working hard
and accepting whatever we get in return.
as a veteran of a dozen or so years of staffing summer camp,
I know that some troops can show up
and they can really make something of their experience,
and some seem to be pulling in the opposite direction,
no matter what you do,
and that's just plain frustrating.
once you run into that sort of frustration,
there are two basic ways to react.
you can change about how you do things
to produce the result that they expect.
in other words, you can alter the program
and you can change everything around
and try and please people who are really difficult to please.
chasing that result, chasing their reaction:
most of the time it leads to shortcuts,
but it gets results and it fulfills expectations,
even if those expectations are pretty hollow.
the other reaction is to work harder,
because working hard is in itself a good thing to do.
if we adhere to an internal standard of value
that energizes our work,
that work is going to be all that much more valuable to others.
the right kind of energetic hard work
with good intentions creates participation and engagement,
and engagement usually fulfills the expectations
of the people you're serving,
creating a positive feedback loop
that energizes everybody.
now scoutmasters experience this.
we can work with the expectation of some result
and mistakenly think that the higher our expectations
of a result the better.
if scouts don't react as we expect,
well, we get frustrated because we're aimed at their reaction.
when we meet with these frustrations and disappointments,
we ought to be able to double down on our efforts
and stop expecting things and start doing things.
we have to be brave and resolute about these things.
examine your own expectations
and understand the value of the work itself.
if your work doesn't advance the aims of scouting,
well, stop doing it that way.
I mean nothing personal,
but we all miss things sometimes.
and double down on work that advances the aim of scouting,
I can guarantee your energy level will rise
and you'll begin to experience better results.
this is podcast number. let's see 234.
that's 234 weekly podcasts.
that's about four years,
and there was a point
where recording a weekly podcast
brought very little in the way of results,
bought very little in the way of reactions,
and I really treasured the very few that I got
because it let me know that this was actually useful to some people.
now, if I had gone on for 50 or 60 podcasts
and nobody reacted positively,
I probably would have given up,
because at that point I would have understood
that what I was doing really didn't have any value to people.
and sometimes it's a big challenge
to turn on the computer and turn on the microphone
and record a podcast every week,
and there are there are periods of time
where I don't get a whole lot of the way of reaction,
but I keep doing it
and this isn't because I'm an especially great person.
okay, I'm pretty convinced that this helps people.
I'm going to keep doing it until I get it right.
234 podcasts later,
I like to think that this helps people more often than not.
the work that you're going to do,
you're going to put it out there,
and the reason that you're going to do it
is because it's the right thing to do,
not because you're hoping that people will react well to it.
and if you don't get the kind of reaction that you expect,
don't blame the customer.
look at yourself,
look at what you're doing
and you might have to make some adjustments to it,
but usually it's just putting a little more hard work into it
that gets the reaction.
so, bringing this back around full circle,
we started by talking about how to resolve conflicts
and how to deal with problems between adult volunteers
or adult volunteers and scouts,
and the way to do. it
is all about perspective and attitude
and having a sense of humor.
the source of a lot of our difficulties is
is we expect everybody to react
to the work that we do in a certain way
and when they don't,
we get disappointment,
and disappointment leads to a lot of negative emotions,
and we kind of get in that spiral
to avoid conflicts and difficulties.
a lot of times,
the thing that we need to do is to concentrate
on doing good work that advances the aims of scouting
music.
well, thanks for listening to this
234th edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can get the scoutmastercg app on google play
or at the itunes app store
and that way you can keep up with all the blog posts
and podcasts and all the videos we make
right there on your mobile device.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
you can join the 6500 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1100 tweeters on twitter.
pin the paltitudinous pictures, proffer publicly
with 1600 other prolific pinners on pinterest.
watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube,
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive scoutmastercg circle on google plus.
now, if you can't face facebook, if twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in pinterest,
you don't put the? u in youtube.
if you're a minus when it comes to google plus
is that what's puttibing you, bunkie?
that's all right, bunkie,
zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
you can get in touch with me. clark green
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
c l a r k e at scoutmastercgcom.
as always, the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
to the boy scouts of america,
nor they endorsed or sponsored by the boy scouts of america.
a it is only me. i'm right here with a microphone and a computer
and i'm trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here is our founder, sir robert middendale.
sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir?
until next time, everyone.